merhaba öncelikle Eee biz size burada
bir robot takımı nasıl kurulur Bunun
tarifini vereceğiz gerekenler sadece iki
öğrenci bir öğretmen ve bir robotik
yarışmasına yolculuk En azından 2008'de
biz bu işe başladığımızda böyleydi
Okulumuzun 41 mezunu merhum Fikret
Yüksel'in kızı Susan burchard Amerika'da
yaşıyor kendisi takımımızın ilk üyeleri
olan iki öğrenciyi ve Değerli
öğretmenimiz müget Tuva iı alıp
Amerika'ya bir robot yarışmasını
gözlemlemeye götürüyor bunu takiben de
elimizden tutuyor yarışmaya katılmamız
ve bir takım oluşturmamızı Hem maddi hem
de manevi açıdan destek oluyor şu anda
19 öğrenci 6 mentör oluşan bir ekibimiz
var yıllar geçtikçe ekibimiz Deek kişi
sayısı arttı Eee ve ekibimiz eki görev
paylaşımları değişti bizim kulübümüzde
robot ve halkla ilişkili olmak üzere
ikiye ayrılıyoruz biz robot kısmı da
kendi içerisinde mekanik programlama
elektronik olarak üç alt gruba ayrılıyor
İlk başlarda kişi sayısı az olduğu için
her bir öğrenciye çok fazla görev
düşüyordu ama yıllar geçtikçe kişi
sayısının artması sayesinde Her bir
öğrenci aldığı görevi daha derinlemesine
daha verimli bir halde yapar oldu
katıldığımız yarışma öğrencilerin
mühendislerden mühendisliği öğrenmesini
geleceğin bilim ve teknoloji liderleri
haline gelmesini Aynı zamanda da biz
topluma duyarlı bireyler haline
getirmeyi amaçlıyor bu amaçları
doğrultusunda yarışmayı organize eden
Vakıf her sene bir görev veriyor ve
robotun inşası için 6 haftalık bir süre
tanıyor bu robot inşasının yanı sıra
topluma duyarlı bireyler olarak bizden
beklenen şey robotiği sistem eğitimi
dediğimiz feni teknolojiyi mühendisliği
ve matematiği çevremize yaymam aynı
zamanda yarışmadan edindiğimiz
kazanımları toplum sorunlarına çözüm
üretmek üz üstünde kullanmamız biz bu
süreci de yolda yürürken Gece yatmadan
önce ders çalışırken Evde otururken Veya
sabah uyandığımızda Kısacası Hayatımızın
her anında aklımıza gelen fikirleri
gerçek hayata geçirerek yapıyoruz bize
verilen 6 haftalık süreç bizim için şu
şekilde gelişiyor bize bir video
yayınlıyorlar Bu videoda o seneki
görevimizin ne olduğunu açıklıyorlar top
atmak çark kasmak tırmanmak oluyor bu
sene öyleydi Biz de sonra takım olarak
oturuyoruz o videoyu analiz ediyoruz
diyoruz biz bu görevlerden hangisini
yapmalıyız hangilerini yapmalıyız ya da
yapmamalıyız puanlarını inceliyoruz ya
da top atacaksa bu topu biz tekerle mi
atmalıyız yoksa mancınıkla mı atmalıyız
buna karar veriyoruz Bir prototip
yapıyoruz ondan sonra bir şasem ii
hazırlıyoruz robot kuracağımız
mekanizmayı hazırlıyoruz ondan sonra biz
bu prototipleri yapmak için gruplara
ayrılıyoruz en verimli olanlarını
topluyoruz bunların genel akışına bir
bakıyoruz karar veriyoruz ve Eee ü
boyutlu ortama geçiyoruz burada Siemens
mühendisleriyle birlikte çalışıyoruz ve
onların yardımıyla üretim aşamasında hem
ham madde kullanırız hem onların
fabrikalarına Hem de kendi atölyemizde
robotun üretimini yapmaya başlıyoruz
üretim yaparken en sona tüm
mekanizmaları birleştiriyoruz
pürüzlerine bakıyoruz robotumuz bir isim
veriyoruz robotumu robotumu bir tema
belirliyoruz robotumu renk veriyoruz
en sonunda robotumu elektronik
parçalarımızı koyuyoruz gerekli
yazılımları yüklüyoruz sürüş
testlerimizi yapıyoruz ve robotumuz 6
haftalık çalışma sürecimizi bitiriyoruz
robotumuz paketliyoruz ve onu Amerika'ya
kargoluyoruz tam 9 yıldır bu işin
içindeyiz bir takım olarak robot
yapıyoruz hiçbir zaman bıkmadık hep daha
nasıl ileriye gidebiliriz kendimizi daha
fazla nasıl geliştirebiliriz diye
düşündük İlk başlarda tecrübesizliği
Türkiye'de başka robot takımı
olmamasından bazı zorluklarla
karşılaştık Tabii ki de mesela robotumuz
da kullanacağımız parçaları Amerika'dan
sipariş etmemiz gerekiyordu ama bu
sipariş ve Kargo süreci çok uzun
olduğundan her parçaya istediğimizde
ulaşamıyorsan Hanım'ın eşi ve bir robot
takımı mezunu Sağ olsunlar Amerika'dan
atölyemize gelerek bize yardımcı
oldular bunlar bizim ilk sorunlarımızı
Daha sonrasında daha farklı sorunlarla
karşılaştık size 6 haftamız var demiştik
robot yapmak için ama biz 2 yıl boyunca
sadece bu 6 Haftanın iki haftasını
kullanabildikleri için 4 hafta boyunca
elimize ulaşmadı ve diğer takımlar 6
hafta boyunca robotlar üzerine
uğraşırken biz sadece 2 haftada robotlar
mızı bitirip yarışmaya gittik 2015
senesinde yeni bir ekip kuruldu herkes
yeniydi hiç kimsenin bir tecrübesi yoktu
ve ilk kez yarışmaya gittik ilk kez o
atmosferi gördük Herkes çok
heyecanlıydı atmosferden büyülenmiş ama
istediğimiz gibi gitmiyordu jürilere
istediğimizi veremiyordu takımımızı tam
olarak onlara
aktaramamak dedik bir toplanalım Bu
böyle olmayacak konuştuk orada biz bu
değiliz dedik Biz daha iyi bir takımız
daha iyi bir Dinamiğin var ve
birbirimize söz verdik ertesi gün jü
geldiğinde varımızı yolumuzu ortaya
koyup bütün enerjimizi bütün
yorgunluğumuzu unutarak onlara kendimizi
anlatacaktı ertesi gün jer geldiler ve
yarım saat boyunca ki normalde 5 dakika
dinlerler diğer takımları bizi
dinlediler Bizim deneyimlerimizi onlarla
paylaştık derdimizi anlattık ve bunun
sonucunda dünya finallerine götüren ü
ödülden biri olan Engineering
inspiration ödülünü kazandık ve
Türkiye'den dünya finallerine
giden takımı
olduk yaşadığımız heyecanlar Her
birimizin hayatlarının farklı
noktalarına dokundu hepimizi ayrı ayrı
motive etti ve etkiledi bunun sonucunda
da hiçbir zaman yorulmayan her robot
sezonuna apayrı bir gazla başlayan
hedeflerine daha çok tutunan ve en
önemlisi de bu yaptığımız işten daha çok
zevk almaya çalışan bir takım haline
geldik yarışmalar 4 gün boyunca sürüyor
program ın yoğunluğundan dolayı erken
saatte kalkmamız geç saatte yatmamız
Bunun üzerinde bir de gün boyu çok
coşkulu bir koşuşturma içerisinde
olmamız gerekiyor Biz bunlara rağmen her
güne bir öncekinden daha heyecanlı ve
daha coşkulu şekilde başlıyoruz ve bize
Bunu yaptıran şey o dört günün her
birinde de eşsiz tecrübeler edinmemiz ve
eşsiz heyecanlar yaşamamız biz dedik ki
biz niye Sadece bu heyecandan Biz
faydalanıyoruz niye diğer okullarda
diğer Gençler yaşlılarımız bu işte
uğraşmıyor Ondan sonra bir sürece girdik
Biz diğer okullarda yeni takımlar açmak
için çalışmalar yaptık Türkiye'deki
robotik yarışmalarına öncülük ettik Hala
da ediyoruz televizyonlara çıktık
radyoya çıktık gazetelerde e web
sitelerinde dergilerde yer aldık ve
okullara gittik dersler verdik
Seminerler verdik hem toplumu
bilinçlendirmek istedik hem de Bu aileyi
genişletmek istedik e ki Nitekim bunu
başardığımızı düşünüyoruz Çünkü biz bu
işe başladığımızda tek Türk takımıyız
Ama şu an Türkiye'de 44 tane robotik
takımı Bu yarışmaya Katılıyor ve dünya
finallerine de gidebiliyor şu ana kadar
şu ana kadar 11 tane robot inşa ettik
ama bu yarışmadan Azıcık da olsa yolu
Geçen herkesin bildiği gibi inşa
ettiğimiz şeyler robottan çok daha
fazlasıydı Bizler topluma duyarlı
bireyler ve girişimci liderler haline
geldik En önemlisi ise bir takım olmayı
başardık ister istemez Yatılı okulda
okuyoruz ister istemez dışarıdan
birazcık da olsa Öyle bir hayat
sürüyoruz Ama bu yarışmaya katıldığımız
günden beri bizim Gözümüz açıldı
çevremizdeki sorunları görmeye görmekle
de kalmayıp onlara çözüm üretmeye
başladık mesela birkaç tane örnek
vereyim Küba'da maddi yetersizlikten
dolayı çocukların defterlerini silip
silip tekrardan kullandıklarını öğrendik
ve onlara defter gönderdik görme engelli
çocukların eğitim gördüğü okullara
giderek onların engellerini kaldırmayı
amaçladık onlarla beraber bilimsel
deneyler yaptık veya takım yeleri olarak
hepimiz organizasyonlarda gönüllü olarak
yer alıyoruz ve çeşitli etkinliklerin
gerçekleşmesine yardımcı oluyoruz Bizim
takım
olarak Bizim takım olarak benimsediğimiz
bir ilke var rekabet içinde işbirliği bu
ülke doğrultusunda Biz diğer takımlarla
yarışma içerisinde rekabet içinde olsak
da sürekli birbirimizle yardımlaşarak
her iki tarafın da kazanmasını
sağlıyoruz Biz kazan kazan politikasını
uygulaya
hem duyarlı hem de profesyonel bireyler
haline geliyoruz Bu süreçten çok şey
öğrendik benliğimize çok şey kattık ve o
yarışma atmosferini Gördük o ruhu
hissettik
E biz her karşılaştığımız sorunda çözüm
odaklı olmaya çalıştık dedik ki biz bu
sorunla şu an karşılaşıyoruz ve Bunu
tecrübe ediyoruz ve eğer ileride
karşılaşırsak ne tepki vereceğimizi
öğreniyoruz politikasını benimsemeye
çalıştık bu sene katıldığımız bölgesel
yarışmasında şampiyonluk ödülünü
aldıktan sonra çok heyecanlıyız çok
coşkulu yuz Tabii ki yerimizde
duramıyoruz gittik hemen sunum
yaptığımız jürileri bulduk dedik ki bize
bu ödülü verdiren şey neydi en çok hangi
noktamız sizi etkiledi bize gün boyu
sunum odasına çok fazla takımın girip
çıktığını ama biz Bizim takım çıktıktan
sonra birbirlerine dönüp işte takım
buydu dediklerini söylediler bu şekilde
de 2017 robot maceramız Dünya
finallerine taşınmış oldu dünyadan
yaklaşık 400 takımın katıldığı dünya
şampiyonasına gittik yarışma boyunca ve
bütün robot sezonu boyunca takım olmak
ve bi yapbozun birbirini tamamlayan parç
parçaları haline gelmek bizim ikinci kez
katıldığımız dünya finallerinde takım
ruhu ödülü kazanmamızı sağladı biz takım
olarak her zaman Birbirimize destek
olduk her zaman ve Buralara Kadar geldik
şu şu anda amacımız daha ileriye gitmek
Ama unutmayın hep birlikte
birlikte Siz yalnız Yalnız yapmıyorsunuz
değil mi Bir ekibiniz var ekip Buraya
gelir
misiniz neri
[Alkış]
ah